hello everyone good morning good evening
and
good afternoon to all of you who have
joined us today
from all across the world we are
delighted to have you all
it gives us immense pleasure to invite
all of you
to this
webinar which is a special one because
we are going to focus
on how to is
a poster presentation post
representation being one of the key
components of
a student's life a researcher's life
it's all
always there in the journey right
we are also very excited because we are
almost towards the start of the omics
research symposium which is going to
happen on march 31st and april 1st
this two-day symposium is going to be a
mega event where
students faculties industrial experts
and scientists from different
backgrounds from different organizations
will
assemble and come together
discuss ideas strategies and
results of all their hard works
throughout the past year
and also brainstorm about other
opportunities
and
exciting events coming up in the future
so
this is something which you don't want
to miss at all
for you will be able to gain so much
information experience
and knowledge from this particular event
the two-day event has been
divided or you can say categorized into
different components namely
bioinformatics education and training
which will be highlighted and covered
on the first day
research cutting-edge science and
industrial applications of
bioinformatics being the other two
categories in which we have divided the
symposium which will be
better highlighted on the second day
that is on april the 1st
during this symposium there will also
also be
a poster presentation competition
where students and researchers from
different backgrounds from different
universities different institutions and
different parts of the world
will showcase their research their
projects their hard work in the form of
a poster which will be evaluated by our
coveted panel of judges
who are from different academic
institutions
different industries
and different research organizations
with loads of experience
in both doing cutting-edge science as
well as training students so this is one
of the greatest opportunity that you
will ever come across
to get feedback
to learn
what you can do from here
what steps would take you to the
pinnacle of success which you dream
about
and ultimately
realize your dream
so if you haven't already
i would recommend you to register for
the symposium it's completely free to be
a listener to listen to the talks
there are other
opportunities as well which i will
highlight later
and you will also get to know about in
today's
webinar
so before we
begin
that
we have peaceful conversation right
thank you
meanwhile
while we are waiting for the start of
today's session we are waiting for
a few more
minutes so that everybody can join in
we would like to know about your
background
what you are currently studying
where are you from what are your
interests
and why
did you
choose bioinformatics or why does
bioinformatics seem interesting to you
what
does it appeal to you and where do you
see yourself with bioinformatics in the
near future so please use the chat
section to
write about it because
it would help us connect
with you better
meanwhile i will keep briefing you about
the symposium so that you can know about
it better
and then we will begin with today's
session
and i am waiting for all of you in the
chat section to know about you all
and finally
i would like to remind you that
the registrations for the symposium are
still open
so please make use of
this time to get yourself a place in the
symposium so that you do not miss
anything
from this particular event all right so
let's not wait and waste any more time
i
with all my
good wishes would like to introduce the
host for today's session today's session
will be guided and directed by miss ruth
vivaja who is the vice president of the
saiyamic student club so from this point
of time i would like to hand over the
stage to miss ruthville
ruth it's all yours please take away
i should project my audible
yes
away good evening to everyone present
over here i am
the current press uh vice president of
the student club for bioinformatics
today we have gathered here for one of
the very auspicious sessions of
the uh uh
yeah of the ceramics club today we would
be discussing about how to ace a first
presentation so shubridge
uh who is the current president of
cyanide student club and i myself am the
vice president of cyanide student club
our community consists of more than
thousand plus students 20 plus
researchers and clinicians and faculties
mentors and peer reviewers to guide us
about how to move forward and how to
enrich our student community
what does what do we do at psionic
student club and how are the topics that
we take are guided into ways to make
students easily understand the basic
bioinformatics so we cover topics of
infectious diseases microbes and
microbiomes precision oncology plant
sciences neuroscience and together with
these topics we help students learn how
to apply big data in biology
one of the main goal of ceramics club is
to help students clear concepts of
bioinformatics not only this but we also
help them to learn about basic insights
about the tools of bioinformatics and
how to apply in the real life research
projects we have brainstorming sessions
so that we can discuss with each other
and get to know the hypothesis that one
can work on and continue to develop as a
project and then into a research paper
we have also a new very evolving field
of how to apply coding and skills of
programming into bioinformatics all this
together helps students and this student
community to understand why
bioinformatics is used and how can we
apply to the clinical problems and other
stuff
the main goal of omics logic company is
to provide training in bioinformatics
and this helps students to enable
independent research which is obviously
guided by our mentors and peer examples
we are here creating a developing and a
growing community which shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of citizens times
we help students clinicians and
faculties of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research projects
using the latest technology and
bioinformatics tools in the current data
science industries
one of the most happening things is the
omics research symposium 2822 that is on
march 31st and april 1st 2022
in opec logic research symposium we
would be discussing various aspects of
machine learning artificial intelligence
bioinformatics astrobiology is one of
the most important fields these days
we have academic experts from middle
university georgetown university top of
bioinformatics center premise life
sciences fab academy we have speakers
from google we have experts from
networking partners such as lbrn hga
bionet
and further on
now one of the main goal that students
faces while going after one university
to another is certain kinds of gaps that
they need to fill on one of the most
important thing that the universities
look for into students are are the
students capable of doing cutting-edge
research just doing any part of research
does not suffice for you to get into a
good recognized university so for that
you have to do a research which stands
out and which really makes an impact
into the scientific community
not only this but universities are also
looking for placements for students so
they want the best of the students and
the best of the students shouldn't know
that what is the current technology what
are the researches that they can apply
the bioinformatic tools and knowledge
into and stuff like that
not only doing research and publishing
papers but how well you can translate
your research into the clinical aspects
or into the translational medicine
aspect so that is taking your research
from the lab that is wet lab or dry lab
to the market
now another question that comes up when
applying for any recruitment
dissertations or internships is what are
the companies looking for so the
companies are looking for students to
provide internships trainings
designation opportunities and further on
they are finding potential employees but
they can be young professionals
middle-aged learners or expertise
and they want their audience to outreach
their programs spread their name and in
order to do this one has to be
self-sufficient one has to be involved
in cutting edge research and should be
aware of the latest technologies codings
programmings and data analytical skills
skills that are available these days
coming to the most important part how
can you connect this all qualities and
what part omits research symposium would
play
if you are part of omics research
symposium this platform will bring you
to a group of experts reviewers
professors and postdoctoral fellows from
one of the most recognized universities
in the world from both academia and
industry
you getting an exposure to these experts
will not only help you recognize where
do you want to go but it would also help
you to know that what the actual
real-life world research demands right
now
you would be exposed to a larger
audience and peers so that you can know
that where you are lacking or how much
far you need to go this would help you
define your skill set and defining your
skill set was the main important part of
any person's cv or resume
you can have an opportunity for
networking and connecting and building
your own professional network which is
in demand these days because as a
researcher or professional in academia
industry one of the most important
qualities that you must possess is
networking talking with peoples getting
to know the scientific research and
further on developing connections which
could be fruitful for you in your future
endeavors
so what's unique about omix logic
students so our students belong to top
universities and schools with whom we
are in constant communication
those universities include m d
university nebraska lsu biomed
georgetown university
our students also have a fine
understanding of basic bioinformatics
tools complex bioinformatic tools and
the bioinformatics concept so that they
can apply this knowledge to real life
independent research projects
such courses introduce bison molecules
biomedical
machine learning transcriptomics
genomics and further on
not only this but our students also know
how to apply these concepts to real
world problems and they then work on one
of the most interesting projects to
solve health related problems or to
develop pipelines and certain machine
learning algorithms
here are the examples of personal
presentations of two of our students who
presented in the omics research
symposium 2021
for omics research symposium 2022 we
have speakers like dr rita sharma who is
an associate professor at bets pilani
should be talking about the emphasizing
role of bioinformatics in every indian
research lab we have speakers from
google that is mark allen who she would
be talking about
google and the nih strides initiatives
we have another speaker from google who
would be speaking about google's partner
programs and resources one of the most
evolving fields these days is carriers
in bio astrobiology dr graham lao phd
from blue marble space institute of
science would be speaking on this topic
and where you can explore your further
carriers in bio in in astrobiology and
we have dr predictive mature from
bioinformatics education at mit
university and should be talking about
aspects of research training and how to
take the bioinformatics education
forward
in omics research symposium 2022 we also
have poster presentation competition
these are the examples of students who
presented last year in omit research
symposium 2021
this year we are covering topics of
omics and bioinformatics ai and machine
learning and data science astrobiology
and spaceomics computational biology and
biotech and pharma
so for today's session we have dr
raghavendra l
he would be talking about the topic how
to ace a poster presentation pertaining
to the omics research
symposium 2022 coming on march 31st and
1st april before we start with this
session let me brief you about dr
raghavendra so dr raghavendran is an
accomplished computational biologist
with more than four years of research
experience in subject areas like
multi-omics data analysis and data
science methods in precision oncology
structural bioinformatics with the
background in biophysics and
bioinformatics he earned his phd in
computational biology from the max plan
institute
germany he has published many research
papers in high impact international peer
review journal prior to joining biotech
as a research consultant and
bioinformatics mentor he served as the
lead postdoctoral research scientist at
the jawaharlal nehru university and
worked on an indo-french collaborative
project on developing machine learning
models for precision oncology
in the course of his research carrier
spanning over 15 years he has worked in
large scale analysis of a wide variety
of big data ranging from public private
patient data on cancer biology plan
sequence data and protein structure data
he is very proficient in using python
and r for bioinformatics he suffers from
a presumably health addiction to
computer programming and data analytics
and is familiar with a variety of
paradigms and they associate the
toolkits he is equally captivated by
life sciences specifically specifically
focusing on translational approaches to
understand cancer biology and
neurological disorders he has been an
enthusiastic mentor to several research
students at find biotech and there's
also experience in tutoring computer
programming courses for graduate
students and working professionals
dr vagavender i request you to join the
session and the stage is all yours
thank you very much
after such a nice introduction i started
to feel very good about myself one more
time
it's
it's very it's very nice to be part of a
part of this student's club it makes me
feel a lot younger than what i am
actually
and let's let me start sharing my screen
and i apologize for my camera is not
working
um
that's an ongoing issue with my computer
that i have to solve at some point of
time
so
so i want to have first few slides or
first few slices um
as interactive as possible so that we
learn
from some of the few examples uh
what we can learn from uh understanding
or from
observing
some good posters some bad posters some
posters that can be uh
improved
so yeah i must confess
right in the beginning that
preparing
preparing posters or preparing slides
for for such topics
was very difficult for me and then
preparing some slides for uh
slicing related to academic or slightly
educational
research and educational
information so
so let's start with the
golden question right what is a
scientific poster so uh i might seem
ancient so because i come from ah
from an era where we used to
start printing the poster hang it up
with the poster wall and
the
the exposure of your poster depends upon
where your poster hangs and
you have to sell your signs
somehow but now it it looks like
we are hoping we will get back those
golden days in the conferences one more
time
but on the other side on the other hand
online
meetings and online conferences has
actually um
can you see me screen i think it says my
screening uh my resume uh sharing is
paused but you can only see my first
screen yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah let me
okay let me stop and share again because
yeah
thank god i noticed yeah okay so this is
where we were and uh
yeah so
so the i was talking about some um
advantages of having an online symposium
an online poster presentation and
how people started to appreciate the um
exclusive inclusivity or inclusiveness
that online symposium online
post a presentation and interaction and
network building efforts have
uh brought up to uh scientific community
so uh cyanomix clubs i think is is also
one of the
uh one of the excellent
beneficiary from from the whole world
moving towards uh
moving towards um
decentralized uh
media decentralized local uh delocalized
decentralized options
so uh let's come back to today's topic
so what is a scientific poster
so
as i said the purpose of a research
poster is to
represent the general overview data the
data and most relevant findings of a
research project so typically research
posters will accompany an oral
presentation of the project conducted or
will accompany some
some presenter who is going to talk to
you or who is going to present
and explain the details of the
scientific poster details of various
sections involving the scientific poster
so that is what i meant by oral
presentation but it should also be able
to independently represent the research
so uh if i see if someone wants to um
scan through the poster and understand
what is the what understand more about
the research and understand more about
the terminologies and
and and the research and their findings
and their conclusion in general the
poster should be able to
hold its ground on itself so
on and all an effective research poster
actually
must provide
a clean and a very consistent layout and
it should actually emphasize the
research question that we have
and it should actually highlight the
important results uh with the using or
with utilizing or with the
with the help of
useful and purposeful graphics and
visuals and it should have readable and
accessible text
it should include citation
wherever it is necessary and also it
should most importantly include your
contact information because posters the
scientific poses are an excellent way
to promote scientific collaborations so
they give you a very
short abstract of you of your long
research career
and also
a long research project that you are
doing and if somebody is interested in
collaborating with your efforts then
they should find a way
to contact you from your research from
your poster so we will start with a good
thing
uh
and a good example of what a brilliant
pose
will look like so
you you start observing uh what a
brilliant what a good poster is a poster
can be first
in a in a landscape format or in a
horizontal format uh wide format
or it can also be in a vertical format i
will give you some examples of vertical
format
so what do you see immediately from this
poster
it has
it is organized very neatly
and it has
readable
sections included
and the alignment and all the other
things are very
precisely organized and
we have independent sections so that
will help us navigate through the poster
but
again this is not a scientific
it's partly a scientific poster but it's
not a very great scientific poster
because
um
we don't know uh
uh
how to navigate this poster we start
with the introduction obviously because
our innate scientific mind always starts
with introduction and then should i
proceed next to food finders or should i
proceed next to pilot study
right should i proceed downs or should i
proceed uh right
so these are the uh
yeah these are some of the
organizational questions that you should
be uh keeping in mind while designing
your poster
so even in brilliantly conducted study
and brilliantly presented poster we can
find some ways to get lost
and this is another
example not on the right side but on the
left side of a poster that is very well
very neatly organized
and
being able to make each and every
section stand out independently will
help you in organizing these posters
[Music]
readability and navigateability okay so
these two slides are
the poster can be horizontal and also
can be vertical
in the in the era of um
physical
process of printing out the poster and
hanging out or hanging out for
displaying the poster there was a or
that still
there is a slight disadvantage in
handling vertical posts because most of
your juicy part of your
research like the results and conclusion
and discussion are going to be the lower
half of the poster for which
scientists and other people has to stoop
down to read it but now
with the digital era
i think
more experienced people in
web development can confirming but the
vertical format is ah
is um
is most preferred because you can uh
align these vertical format very neatly
uh
in the in a web page um
and and towards the right you have
a poster that looks like it has been
built in last 15 minutes so that's a
very badly organized poster
uh it does
sections uh it has very um
[Music]
improper use of fonts and not very
clear readabilities it's been it's been
given here so we will start looking
through some of the examples these
posters and then start building our own
formula for how a good poster should
look like and what we can learn from a
very neatly presented and good poster so
after these two
introduction slides so let
uh i'll let the audience decide the
quality of this poster
if you
want to um
have this poster or if you come across
this poster would you tell this poster
as excellently organized and would you
uh
tell to give this poster a positive
feedback
please update me on the chat quick quick
quick let's go through it let's have it
little bit uh
interactive before i go on and on
about this one okay
next
here we have contracting uh opinions and
some more okay too much text yes we have
contradicting opinion too detailed for
me okay but body yeah so i think if i
can summarize people like the
organization part of this poster
but they dislike the amount of text that
is present in this poster and exactly
that is the case right
this is
not an example of an excellent poster
because of several reasons and those
reasons are not
limited to
organizational or more words this one
right
it's it's generally about
i mean first about amount of words yes
that is right too much too many words
and there are alignment problems there
is too many too much information into
very small area
and
i mean yeah the placement of logos is i
mean that that's a personal opinion but
uh
people wanted some some
some people want some photos and some
people do not want some uh logos and etc
so
yeah
some of the uh
some of the
critiques in these uh in this part of
this particular poster can be debatable
but in general um
it has a lot of data it has lot of words
but
so that is why that is why it is very
difficult to read and it is very
difficult to follow
so another example of a poster is uh
this poster also has an excellent
organization as i talked about so you
start reading from the background and
you go to the present study and then go
to the methods and where you go
you go to the right side or you go to
the left side and how it is organized so
until except for this specific section
and these some of these sections ah
acknowledgements and references being
very
with i mean being presented with a very
small font size can be um forgiven
but there is one part of the result
which is given at a lower font size even
than acknowledgement so that is that is
absolutely wrong so it is very difficult
to uh
read these sections of the poster so you
have to prioritize and you have to uh
identify what do you want to present in
a poster so
these uh so we learned two important
things
one the poster cannot be wordy two wordy
two the poster has to have uh an
excellent navigational or excellent
purpose of
directing the
user or directing the
audience to specifically where we want
them to go or where we want them to
focus on okay so what will you tell
about this poster is this poster a good
poster or is this poster can be improved
a little bit more
we will come to that yamna and we are
going to discuss that in detail we are
just going quickly going through what we
already know about the poster and from
what we know and from what we uh observe
uh what we can conclude and what we can
take away and then i'll go in detail
about different sections of the poster
in the following slides so
what do you see in this poster is this
poster a good poster or is this poster
can be improved or is it is it working
for you and uh yeah please
yeah
please let me know
so i have a comment which says can
abstract be removed i will talk about
abstract in the following slides
excellent questions already so people
are getting into the group so some more
come on come on more more can you follow
this poster
what can be improved or what can be
added upon and what can be removed on is
it is this poster generally working for
you or not
yes
okay excellent so i i got the bullseye
right in the second or third comment
so it has a lot of graphical information
that is correct but
correlating text that
infers or that actually
gathers the results from uh
from the graphical output or from the
bar graphs is missing it it gives lot of
bar graph information but what do we
read from this bar graphs that is not
very clear even
even in the
this is not even from the um
figure legends are also not clear so we
have to go to conclusion and then look
for a search for
those specific comparison and come back
to conclusion which is not a very good
navigational
option but in general this poster is
organized pretty well it is almost there
it's close there it has introduction it
has methods
as pictures so that
that it's not too wordy and it has
hypotheses also but if
possible we can improve this poster by
reducing or by completely removing the
abstract and by including uh bullet
points of results uh along or next to
each and every one of those uh
comparison or bar plots that are uh that
is being displayed
so
yeah let's move forward so from from
what we have already observed so let's
uh start summarizing um
what we have learned so far from from
couple of uh important posters and what
we have learned
usually eyes read from top to bottom and
for most of the people i see it from
left to right so a column format will be
extremely helpful and
all of our most of us would have enjoyed
some comics in our younger age so
if it is not explicitly numbered we go
from
left to right and
and the long columns will be read first
so that is how a poster will also
is also like expected to be organized
okay
and
use sections
uh and use small
boxes or small sections of
sub sections and sections of
information so that people can get a
feeling of uh navigating through your
poster if your poster is a is an ex is
an expanded version of your paper or of
your abstract or of your profile or of
your proposal then that's not a good
poster at all even even if it contains
lot of pictures it should not have um
complete
complete text information so people have
um
people can follow or read from anywhere
between 12 to 16 words in one line
on a horizontal poster
and even less than 10 12
less than 10 words on a vertical poster
if you use
in one line
so use sections and headings that will
give a navigational aspect to the
posters and
use a lot of graphics instead of text
but graphic uh you should accompany
these graphics with what do you learn
it's actually your research and you
cannot just put on some of the plots
like we saw in couple of slides ago and
expect the user to make the connection
you should make the connection and tell
them where you made this connection from
by displaying the plots by putting up or
by including the
graph graphics so these graphics can be
comparative flaws these graphic graphics
can be pictures of the experiments and
whistles that you perform and these
graphics can be results of the analysis
that you um
that you
calculated
so we should definitely include high
resolution pictures that is extremely
imperative in this age or era or
a digital
poster presentation and we should label
each axis with units we should include
legends for color legends or shape
resins for different
graphics
plots and
comparative plots and comparative
graphics that we used so far
so
um
if you want to include text how should
you include text we should include text
in short phrases and in
if possible in bullet points if
you have or i have also seen or it is
also quite
common not to include bullet points for
conclusion or specifically for a
discussion if discussion is included in
the poster uh
there the aim is to
build a cohesive uh
argument or cohesive speculation of the
results that we have so it is quite
okay to
have
texts in short phrases and not long
complex statements in the discussion
part if you want to include discussion
but mostly conclusions or summary is
preferred over discussion in a
in a poster presentation
so
we we can include text but at which font
size that's a golden question and which
font says can anybody guess
if you had made some poster and if you
have some
common
example of
making and developing posters then you
should know what is the absolute minimum
font size
that you can make this poster make a
poster with
yeah 32 is very conservative excellent
yeah 24 right nothing less than 24.
this 24 font size on a uh i mean
nowadays font size depends upon the font
but on a normal uh fonts like um aerial
calibri
and on these fonts then any nothing
anything between 24 and 24 and above or
anything between 24 to 32 for your a
normal text should be good enough for
the
visualize for the
participant or for the audience to read
it from approximately 4 to 6 feet
far from the poster that is the aim so
anything
smaller than 24 is not going to be very
legible and some texts like
references like acknowledgements like
funding acknowledgments
and like special
cases
these can be a little bit smaller than
24 to save or to have some
to have some space really in the poster
so headings must be around 70 72 around
this this um and
size because headings are the one or
titles and headings of the one that
actually pull people from far away so it
has to be
right at that number or so that it is
legible and clear
so you should learn a little bit about
visual hierarchy when you are going to
present the poster so spend some time in
reading this slide so what do you see do
you see all the all that is given in
this
visual hierarchy
so you can form
a
priority or the priority in which you
are reading these different texts all by
yourself
right
so you will read bold text first and you
will read brightly colored text first
and you will read the text that is
presented in a
font that is not very difficult to read
first and you will completely skip if
the text mingles or if the text is
somehow
similar to the background color or the
text is too light it's very difficult to
read even if you skim so you should keep
this in mind and and
make your
posters or make the text in your posters
readable
and
by make by
by mentioning this and you cannot just
make
each and every line or each and every
word of your poster to be bold at 32
font so that is also not going to be
very good so contrast is very important
which point that you want the
participant or that you want the
audience to highlight so those things
you should actually decide
when
generally when designing a poster
so
there are some font styles which are
extremely pleasing to read from distant
and some font size which are not very
pleasing to read
so you can use some i will also give
some more cheat sheets about some font
combinations and color combinations
later so which can which you can explore
um for the possibility of using
different font sizes because we don't
want to end up using the same font size
for everybody um if you have the freedom
to use different font size explore
uh i have a question on which is the
best software to use uh used to design a
poster
nowadays excellent posters can be
designed on microsoft powerpoint itself
so
powerpoint has the capacity to uh design
excellent posters you can leverage the
use of powerpoint i will talk a little
bit about some important technical
aspects of powerpoint later i think i
have it in one or two slides i will i
will come back to that point right okay
and if you have to use background don't
use distracting background
so uh
use a background that that is not
distracting the background should as the
name suggest should
should not actually compete with the
information that you have
so
use
light or
fair backgrounds with the dark letters
that seems very uh
easy and legible to read and not very
dark backgrounds overall with
with the white or with the bright
letters that is that is not very very
much prefer
um
because you have to change everything
from the from the plots that you make
from the table that you make everything
depending upon
your choice of the background so
generally a
light background or lightish background
with a very soft gradient
gives a very pleasing
look and feeling and welcoming warm
welcoming feeling to your posters
so
a typical organization of the poster
depends on what you want to include and
how do you want to include so you can
have lot of flexibility in the poster
depending upon what do you want to add
and
how how you are
study how your study dictates what you
want to add so
in an academic setting when you want to
present the poster that involves
multiple authors and you can uh you can
stick to the order of the author but you
have to highlight the author who is
presenting the poster right here title
should not be more than two lines
at its most it should be one and a half
lines or two lines uh it should not be
more than two lines if it is more than
two lines then uh that is not uh
people lose interest in in the title
itself so it should not be more than two
lines and then you can have sections
organized as as you wish you can have an
abstract you can have introduction you
can have methods and results and you can
have yeah multiple results and
conclusion and references so you can
change up these sections these are not
hard
hard rules that you have to stick to
these sections all the way uh always so
for example if my um
paper or if my uh
work uh is not about
it does not involve lot of method then i
can change up or
use a lot of
area for results to discuss results and
i can
eliminate the abstract completely and
then move the methods down here and do
all sorts of things that i want to uh
change that i want in my poster so it is
in fact my poster and within the given
real estate you can change up the
organization of the post
to suit your data and to suit your uh
study uh best right
keeping in mind uh the flow keeping in
mind the readability and keeping in mind
the general template that you want to
stick to
so
where do we begin so what do we how do
we start building a poster okay
where do we begin so we have to first
find out
[Music]
is it okay to use some sort of arrows
that do not look out to keep
flow with the headline if you want to
um
if you uh if you want to navi if you
want to help in in the poster navigation
you can use numbers
one introduction two methods three
results a four results b
five conclusion six references that is
better than giving arrows okay
then using arrows for the flow of
headaches um because yeah depending upon
how much text you have and how much
information you have you have to have
you have to make some sort of uh
compromises on the navigation stability
and readability and also
general organization of the poster so
let's let's come back so when you have
completed your project or when you have
your project ready for
most of the analysis ready and most of
the interpretation has been going on so
you have to start asking
what is the one most important
finding that i from my research project
that i want to share with people
if all the posters can include just only
one line what will that one line be in
my poster so that is
the most important uh
question that you should answer from
your research you should write it down
and write possible candidates for this
specific uh question and then come back
later because it's um we work very well
when we work subconsciously so come back
later and then you started you you start
precipitating the order or the priority
of very interest extremely interesting
finding in your research project
and then second one how can you actually
use
different visual elements like charts
graphs pictures
and
flowcharts that is going to help you
share that one interesting finding with
the conference attendees so everything
depends upon that one hero that one
highlight right that one
protagonist
that you want to highlight that you want
to support uh with the use of other
tools
and
what
it is just not sufficient to add
everything in your poster and then take
a break and go to your uh yeah take a
break and wander off like that right you
have to think about what should i talk i
obviously cannot read if you uh if you
are just going to read what's in the
poster then why are you there people can
read themselves so you have to tell them
tell tell the people what's in the
poster all right this is very important
in the era of digital
poster presentation because um people
including the jury members and other
participants have access to your posters
all the time they can they can look at
your poster race in currently they can
look at your poster while some other not
non interesting session is going on so
if you are just going to read what's in
the poster then
that's not
that is not enough in this era so you
have to
find out you have to write it write
write it down or you have to narrow it
down to what you what is the information
that you want to convey
like the information should be about
how did you start your experiments or
how did you start your research um so
that all of your research focuses on
finding that one most important thing
in your research project
so that if you start building you
building up like this then
you will start uh you will start forming
a story so when when a story builds then
uh you will have lot to discuss about
your
your poster so in the poster context uh
the three m's that we should keep in
mind when creating a research poster is
um
regarding message medium and materiality
are the three components or central
components that should come together
so that you can
you can make or you can form a context
for your search posters so within these
three messages and mediums and
materialities so you have to first
narrow it down
about the message right who is your
audience is your audience
all of your audience are senior pros in
the research are all of your audience
and most of your audience are
your peer members like
fellow
fellow students and senior students and
junior students etc so what are you
trying to communicate to them this your
area
is one of the popular areas where
everybody has some introduction or
background too or do you have to spend
some time in explaining your background
or your area the project's background
little bit to
uh to the audience those are the context
that you want to
keep your eye on keep your um uh
yeah keep your uh keep and keep it in
your mind so
again as i mentioned what is the one
most important message that you want to
convey with your research portion that
you have to identify
and in the medium where are you
presenting this information are you
presenting this in uh
in an um in an asynchronous format like
and also synchronous format like
in person or in a virtual
conference and how will you be sharing
your work will you be uh recording uh
will you be recording a short message
about your poster representation about
your poster or will you be presenting it
live to people so the uh and your script
or your
medium of explaining or discussing your
poster will change depending upon what
you are maybe depending upon the medium
that you want to present your results
supposed to your process on
so
in the materiality it's about
it's about how can your research be uh
applicable beyond the context of or
beyond the uh um
beyond the restrictions of your field
right what is the importance of this
information let's say okay
i found out that um
by by benchmarking something like 15
different machine learning algorithms on
a simulated data set i found some of the
algorithms performed better is this a
good word maybe yes it is i spent
something like one and a half 100 years
to do this
is this important work i don't know
because who cares about simulated data
so is this is this work interesting to
many people i again don't know unless
and until you apply this to real world
data nobody is interested in simulated
data for
estimating the accuracy of machine
learning algorithms so
a lot of different things should go into
deciding that what one most important
message and how that important message
can be packaged so that you can um you
know you can show it to uh your peers
most of the people who are going to read
your courses are not going to be
experts in your research area so they
are going to be scientists and they are
going to be
on their way to becoming a scientist but
they might not be expert in that
in the exact analysis methods or in the
exact
processes that you took to obtain this
research so you have to decide um upon
the importance of information and how
you are how your research topic is going
to be presented ah in a relevant way to
your audience and in the field of study
so um
while moving on let's
talk a little bit about uh appearance so
technicality so apart from this from
these generalized context of identifying
what are present in the poster you will
find lots of what to do what not to do
in in generally in i mean scattered all
over the internet about about the
posters right so you
i will give you pointers in what to add
in the posters then you can use those
guidelines and pointers to fill a rough
draft so that your poster you can come
to shape instead of just
talking about a generalized concept of
what a poster should look like and how
do you
identify your research question and
sorry how do you identify your most
important message so
in appearance your poster appearance it
can it depends upon what do you want to
how do you want to
organize a poster you can organize the
poster as uh horizontal uh or vertical
and uh as a three column as a four
column anything more than three column
in horizontal or even in vertical is is
not going to be very legible i will tell
you
so if it's vertical it's two column and
if it's horizontal it's a three column
so uh inside the poster's appearance um
some general acceptable uh uh
and not acceptable
patterns are you can have images
uh uh in the introduction but that is
going to eat up some of the real estate
in the introduction so mostly that is
not preferred uh but you can have if you
absolutely want to
introduce some of scientific some of the
existing um
research or existing conditions you can
have introduction right introduction is
all about
why did you choose to study this topic
and why did you choose to
perform this analysis in this
specific system so introducing the
system introducing the introducing your
study introducing your data is what
introduction is called
so methods um can be flow chart or can
be ah
can be some sort of
graphics are and there can also be
bullet points so it depends on what you
want to add but mostly preferred is
methods can be
something that you can relate
that connects or connects a sequence of
events or sequence of um
designs so in the results obviously you
you should have a lot of figures line
graphs they are common excellent and
then
in discussions i just spoke about
discussions being not bulleted but it's
yeah it's often bulleted but um you
should
mostly conclusion and
summaries are preferred over discussion
uh
because yeah you you will often not have
enough space to discuss enough things in
the in a research poster so um we spoke
about neutral backgrounds we spoke about
uh not very strong
highlighting backgrounds and yeah
distracting backgrounds and
yeah use use some uh
good white space uh in your poster uh
and uh don't clam it uh like what we
have uh
what we saw in the first few slides and
a general size guide or number guide for
how much information that you should add
in your poster is about like this the
titles should not be more than one and a
half or two lines and the introduction
is about 200 250 words and in aims or
specific aims or objectives of your
research work should should be less than
100 words it should not be it should not
go on and on
most more often than not the hypotheses
or the objectives are the shortest uh or
smallest portion of your poster and
again materials and methods should not
be more than uh 150 or 200 words um
yes you can have my slides yes so should
not be more than 200 words and
if it is becoming a little bit bigger
please try to condense it into some sort
of
flow chart or some sort of flow diagram
that people can follow you do not have
to explain everything you don't have to
explain how you are doing western blot
you don't have to explain how you are
doing pca plot right these are the
things that people can understand uh so
you don't have to explain how you did it
you just have to find out
a precise balance between what you did
and
explaining what is it
what are the
methodologies that are not very common
or if you have used any uh
specifically
different methods that you can you have
to mention that you can mention and
your results should always accompany the
figures and it should not be too wordy
uh results should actually tell what you
see from the figures and results should
not have conclusion right you see what i
mean you have to tell what do you
observe from the figure and you can tell
what you you find uh some of the
implications from those uh observations
like um
a is greater than b so uh why is that a
uh i mean why did do you think a could
be greater than b or what is the effect
of a being greater than b a is greater
than b and this a being better can
can affect or can result in c being
greater than b and etcetera etcetera and
a and c being greater than the samples
ah this set of samples can be due to
this set of samples being recorded under
this condition they are from this dc
sample etcetera etcetera and a and b are
implicated in these diseases in ah in
few of the
prior research that is already been
performed so this is how you can expand
on your research but not more than
results not more than 200 words
something like that right
if you have to include acknowledgements
you can include acknowledgements but
very
little because sometimes when when you
are doing funded research it is it is
expected that you include some
acknowledgements of those funding
resources so um you can just mention
their logos and you can just say
acknowledgements those logos that's fine
you have to include references that is
one place where you should never ever
compromise you can make it however small
you want to make it but you have to
include references you you obviously you
cannot perform any research without
without
referring to some of the prior
researches
prior work so you have to include as a
search
reference
so if you want to go one by one we can
go so title and abstract most of the
posters will not have abstract because
my personal understanding and my
personal view is you are post this
object of your study so you don't want
to have another object of the of
existing abstract so uh you can use
those
section for
for explaining a bit on the background
or or
adding some more conclusion or adding
some results part and sometimes you
might be stuck
in some organize or in some necessity
with some necessity that you have to
include abstract then you can have the
abstract at its minimal uh
that is absolutely a minimal requirement
you can have
and
you know what to include that you
shouldn't you should include the
question i mean you you all of you would
have submitted abstract to the uh
symposium that we already have or most
of you would have done it so you should
include what are you researching you
should include what the method that you
use and what did you observe and what
are the implications of those results
and observations and what are the major
findings and conclusions that is if you
start answering all these question in
two lines in two lines you will you will
arrive at a 200 word abstract
so that is that is how abstracts are
formed and after this you have to
improve those that paragraph for
better flow better highlighting and
etcetera etcetera but this is how
abstracts are done um
so your introduction or background
should not be a copy of your option it
is completely separate it actually tells
you uh what are the current or what are
the current research that is going on
that is related to what you have
researched and where is the gap
the main flow or necessity to
introduction or to the interaction piece
is to introduce to the audience
how or what has been done in this in the
system that you are working or in the
field that you are working and how these
two combine
to uh present you with a gap that you
are addressing that gap
and
so when you do this you will arrive at a
purpose or a hypothesis or a specific
game for your
work for your
project so that is where interaction to
culminate into so you start introducing
about
the general aspect if i am working on
cancer genomics i will start introducing
about cancer being the deadly disease
and then
slowly focusing on which cancer that i
am going to focus on and then second
up in that cancer
what what is the model system that i am
working that i am
taking the data from that that i will
focus on and then in the third paragraph
or in the third section how these two
combine how ah i am using this model
system to answer a general question
about the cancer biology that is not
answered so far and what are the
specific methods that you use to do this
and what do you find that that will
finish up your introduction and then
this comes nicely or this goes nicely
with ah with a with a very specific
hypothesis or aim that you are going to
um
form formulate at the end of um
yeah at the end of your uh introduction
so that should naturally flow into the
problem statement or the aim of the
project or hypothesis of the project
depend on what you are
doing so um
so that is uh
it it can be embedded within the
introduction but it it it adds more
value even however small it is it has
more value if you add it as a separate
section so people sometimes many people
will just skim only the aim of the
project or specific game of the project
so that if they find whether that goal
or that objective uh pleases them and
introduce and and
in uh interest them to uh proceed
further to read about your poster and
then comes methods we spoke a little bit
more about these methods so method
should not be like this or like this it
can partially be like this it is
acceptable because this tells some story
and this gives some
image
picture pictorial representation and
something related to that but materials
and methods should not be like this is
like i copied and paste from
from publication so
your poster is not a is not a copy paste
from your publication or your draft so
you don't do that um
yeah sure sure usma i think cyanx will
take care of that so method this is this
is an excellent method maybe a couple of
lines and
a couple of lines added to this will
will explain uh will make this method
complete and you can have
if you want to have
text a lot of text in a method please
use bulleted points that will declutter
lot of your
clutter in in the text you can have
short strong statements add bulleted
points instead of
making a statement like i took this data
submitted made this pre-processing and
submitted to this analysis you can do
the data was
this analysis was performed on the data
finished if people want to know more
about that analysis they can look it up
and then comes important part images
charts and graphs and which you should
or you will include in the results
section i think i was intended to
add this after this okay but that's okay
we can we can take a good look of look
about this so you remove unnecessary
borders you remove unnecessary
backgrounds remove unnecessary lines and
remove
not very clear labels and markers from
from your plots which are default option
of excel don't just make a plot in excel
and then copy and paste it in your
poster it is going to come up with the
bluish gray background and that's not
going to look very good
so yeah use solid colors and flat styles
and
yeah and not very bad table so this is a
very this is an example of a table that
you often see in
word or in or in mac
pages but it's not a very good table
it's a very bad thing use table like
this and tables you don't need a
vertical line for the tables so you yeah
and yeah
you don't need horizontal lines for the
tables you can have vertical lines but
something like this looks really
pleasing and really good um
and yeah so um
most of your charts should be
accompanied with something uh about what
you perceive here you you whether you
perceive the uh that and the blue is
consistently higher in all the
comparison or the blue is higher in some
of the comparison are the red started
increasing as the comparisons of the
categories go along so you have to
find what is important finding from your
poster and then you have to add those
lines precisely next so
results will form bulk of your poster
section right in in
in terms of occupying the real estate or
and also in terms of
material and in terms of
stuff that you want to put
images and the text that you want to put
in more often than not you will struggle
with what to have and what to leave
so
it will change depending upon the field
that you are working on but more mostly
it is going to be one big column and
this is going to be the section that
summarizes
your important findings
of all the analysis or important
analysis that you did and you have to
draw
what do you or you have to
make
specific or make
important implications and conclusions
from this and how it leads to
how it leads to your one
important finding so that should be
highlighted and how different results
combine so that combined to
come to make you conclude that one very
big important finding that is where your
results should lead to
excuse me if it is possible
unless and until it is necessary do not
use long tables if you use long tables
it becomes it's very difficult to read
it's very difficult for people to follow
and it's very difficult for you to
explain also if you can concise or if
you can condense that table into some
sort of pictorial graphical
representation that is excellent
but if you absolutely must have tables
have tables that that is not more than
something like this not more than five
rows and four or five columns that's
that is the maximum that you can have a
table anything more than that is going
to clutter make your
um results look really cutting and
you can have something like what people
do in uh
in physical poster presentation is have
a handout in those they will have
appendix where you can paste lot of big
tables if you really want but now i
think when the uh
in the
online and in the
in this era
in the digital era
they do not give the possibility or give
the option of adding some supplementary
materials and that is to be considered
for many people
so
what is a general rule a general rule is
one paragraph should uh
should accompany each image section like
these two are one image section so what
do you learn from these two images of
these two comparison that is one small
section and these two are one small
section so you should have uh something
written what do you
learn from these two images so if you
have all of these then it's very
difficult to
very difficult to
refer to where and what so if you write
even a big paragraph of robot referring
first go to a i can put that from a and
go to b i can put that from b go to c
and c implicates this and d d gives you
important resources that is very bad
so you take this as a separate section
and within those first two add what you
learn from prostitute and the next two
add what you learn from next to and the
next remaining plots are you learn from
what these plots tell you uh these plots
can be arranged in the ah
in the
in the um
algorithmic or in the
what do you say
in the order in which you did the
analysis or this this most more most
likely or most preferred this has to be
arranged in the story in the order of
the story that you want to tell it can
be variable uh happen that you performed
one of the key uh analysis in the later
part of your uh
chronological order but that becomes one
of the key component in first few uh
identification or first few sections of
the results like uh yeah so those can
those can also happen and you you found
out that you have to fill some of the
exploratory analysis that you have not
performed uh
earlier so if you perform those
exploratory analysis at last that not be
mentioned in last so that has to be
exploratory analysis has to come in the
beginning uh when you are explaining
your data so for i mean yeah these
sections plus um
you can add something about the data if
you are for mostly for biological or
bioinformatics people who are taking
publicly available data to uh to perform
this analysis so your methods section
can include data so that is materials
and methods right so material include
the data so you there you can actually
talk about the data set that you
downloaded the data set that you chose
for the little bit about the data set
and
where to find the data set and how did
you get the data set what this data set
generally have like a very small pivot
table and very small
table in terms of number like this many
normal samples of tumor
triple negative breast cancer is
compared with this many um
treatment sensitive samples of triple
negative breast cancer so that that you
can have it in the
material section now i wanted to tell in
the material section i forgot that so
finally your summary and conclusions so
it is preferred you have somebody in
conclusions like this like bulleted
points so that it flows and people tend
to remind remember and keep lot of
things in their mind when they when it
is presented as a list or as a bulleted
point and not as a summary of
conclusions in uh in like what you
obviously see in
publications
like
your summary should be
one result or that most famous result
that we talk about right that take home
result that you want to uh what that you
want the uh viewer that you want the uh
[Music]
participant or that you want the
audience to take home with so
you
you mentioned some specific game whether
or not did you succeed in uh
answering those questions in this
specific game you should always relate
to that your result or your conclusions
or your summary should always result to
that if i my specific specific game is
to uh if i have stated that um i want to
find out if genomics data can actually
um
can actually help me categorize the
locations of hydronic carcinoma then i
should tell whether or not i succeeded
in this effort like
i tried it it did not work i need more
data this can also happen
within the within the realm of within
the availability of percent data i
concluded this this i can
say with 50 or 60
70 certainty that i can sufficiently
categorize a hidden carcinoma from
different uh sources based on gene
expression data so always your primary
result in the summary of conclusion to
relate to the hypothesis or to relate to
the specific gain that you have
mentioned in the
in the paper or sorry in the
poster use similar wording if you have
used something like transcriptomics data
aim is to identify whether
transcriptomics landscape can explain
breast cancer subtypes then you cannot
you cannot add i used rna-seq data to
understand or these are basic data can
actually understand
tumor landscapes or tumor subtypes so
make it in such a way that people who
are not familiar familiar with the
terminologies in your field can relate
if you use transcriptomic data in the
hypothesis use transcriptomic data in
the conclusion if you use rna-seq data
rna-seq pipeline rna-seq analysis right
throughout your
your
poster flow use the same word in the
conclusion in summary don't mix much
there may be multiple
words and jargons associated with one
specific
meaning one specific data or one
specific type don't mix match that is
going that is going to be inconsistent
and people are not going to follow it
okay
and definitely add reference references
can be added in multiple ways it can be
added in different formats use the
smallest and shortest format that
goes along
with with the space that has been
available to you and with the format
that has been supported definitely add
reference you should add
definitely add references to your study
you can obviously would not have been
able to do this study without references
so definitely add references and
refer those references in the in
introduction and then when you are
relating that in in summary and
conclusion refer those surfaces just
don't add these references the point
just references cite those references in
the introduction so when you say that
cancer is the deadly disease it is going
to it has already caused 40 million
people death in in the last these many
years i have to refer that disease from
the
cancer genomics of gdc or tcga data so i
have to refer that ah
you have to recite that so recite it
and let's let's talk about some cheat
sheets or some cheats uh about how to uh
understand how to go about poster
organizing the poster as i mentioned
so uh four horizontal organization is is
is the maximum that you can take in a uh
in a poster organization that is that is
horizontal and not more than two in the
vertical format and you can have
different document size like 36 and 54
and 72 here comes the power point
tidbit that i want to tell you if you
are going to use powerpoint to make your
poster i think there is a limit of 56
inches on both the height and width of
the slide right you cannot have more
than 56 inches in the
height and width of the slide but you
can have proportional sizes if you want
to have something like this 72 inches so
you divide this by two you make 36 by 24
and then you make your powerpoint
presentation and you zoom it to 200. you
set the page size before start making
your powerpoint before making your
poster in powerpoint because if you
start making your poster in some
different free form then start to
condense it into into
into necessary size unnecessary page
setup then powerpoint is going to ask
you should i expand or should i collapse
so that is going to mess up with the
alignment mess up with the font size
mess up with a lot of things in your
poster organization so postal
presentation so don't do this mistake
that i have done a lot of times so first
set the page setup and multiple uh
multiple pages of the same page setup in
the powerpoint presentation you can have
multiple drafts in that way
so that you can track the progress of
your post representation and then your
poster layout right
what are the good layout and what are
bad layouts you can have if you want to
have
graphs at any form
right on plots in any form these are the
acceptable poster layout do not use
layouts like what they use in newspaper
do not fill these pages with uh
with the text that is a very bad
poster layout right and if if it's a
circular plot or if it's a network plot
if you have lot of white space around
this plot it does not matter it has to
stand alone it has to stand alone within
the squarish area within the
encompassing square area that it has to
stand along you cannot fill this area
with
with the text that people want to read
so people should read no
this can have legends and this can have
information related to pointers related
to this specific pie chart or the
specific graph but not the readable text
it cannot have the readable text so
please use a layout that makes sense
with the
with the research that you are going to
use and then these are some of the basic
layers that you can use and these are
some of the basic cheats for uh title
for the uh for the other font sizes that
you have so some people somebody asked
me about headings so use heading that is
highlighted in a separate section do not
use heading that is that flows along
with the line of the text so this
becomes very difficult to find out where
the settings are you can have numbers
here
in this heading so that you can uh
generally direct people to where they
want to go and these are excellent
headings and this is very bad background
because we don't
we cannot see what's going on and you
have to select your background really
very nicely and these are some of the
some of the font size and how those
fonts will look right you can mix match
this uh so that you can have a very uh
unique uh presentation uh style for your
poster so um yeah
yeah so at
aim should be to make the make the
viewer easily identify each and every
section of your poster and and follow
and follow the uh
flow that you want them to follow right
and let's move on like some of the
colors which will go very well with each
other right
red background blue title or blue uh
font will never work don't ever do that
it's very difficult to read you you can
make one in the powerpoint and try to
read it from like two feet away you will
not be able to make out and similarly
blue background red
dots or red color
font will never work
so if you want to use red or green or
blue background use whitish grayish or
bright colored
fonts so those will work very well with
each other right very well with
with them together so don't uh just
because you like red and blue don't
make them make the master so this is a
bad alignment that i was talking about
don't do this even some even many
newspapers do that do this this is very
difficult to read and it will look
cramped up and it will look really messy
so i think yeah with that i conclude i
hope uh you you all had a lot of very
valuable information and very good
direction in how to design your posters
and yeah i can i can take some of the
questions if you have any and i can
share this presentation with you and i
add some of the references that i use
for this presentation in the appendix
and then i can share it with you so that
you can
take information from this poster or
from the referred media that i used to
make these forecasts thank you very much
and i hand it over to uh ruthvi i think
yeah
thank you so much dr raghavendra this
was really an enlightening talk for
students like us to understand about how
to you know actually present a posture
i'm very sure it's very helpful to
others as well
so are there any questions in the chat
box
um i think yeah can you just tell a bit
about plagiarism while making postures
uh you should not plagiarize definitely
you should not plagiarize that's that's
nothing about that if you want to code
you can quote right like many budding
scientists or many people like you when
you are coming up you will struggle to
reformat uh the introduction section
right if you want to
add the introduction section from some
court introduction section or site
interaction section from some other
paper you will struggle to
reformat that into
some other wordings or some other words
so in that case if you absolutely want
to take the exactly some same words you
can quote
like i did it right cancer is the
leading cause of death it already killed
something like 10 million people uh so
far so this as quoted by this source you
can code obviously you cannot use it for
all the all the lines in your
introduction so for specific things that
you can quote uh you can do that but uh
don't plagiarize um about i mean for
about anything for right for anything
you can you can modify it
you don't you should not absolutely copy
and paste it if you want to use uh
um yes for example if you want to use
some of the
um
[Music]
for example like the effect of cancer or
the
the availability of big data if you want
to put graphics there you can you cite
them so you can just write below the
graphics you cite from which website you
took this picture or you can modify that
picture
by you right modification is not
cropping cropping is not modification
taking a picture and then cropping their
logo is not modification modification is
that that
taking that picture and extracting the
data from the picture making the picture
again in your computer is what is
modification so that is not plagiarism
that is modified picture that you
recreated that picture in your own
computer uh based on the existing data
so that is not modification so some of
the pictures are available freely
creative common license like wikipedia
so those you don't have to feel bad
about you can just mention it and then
just give give proper
sighting like wikipedia this link finish
so you can do that
so don't pick your eyes try to change it
up a little bit replace it
change it up a little bit so that you
don't end up plagiarizing so um
a good writing flow is if you want to
absolutely take some
some section some introduction some
interaction from this paper some
introduction part from that paper
another interaction from this paper you
copy everything and then put it in a
word word document and
try to write it try to type it the same
word try to type it again so when you
are typing it exactly same word looking
at that and typing you will start
forming your own sentences and your own
statements because you are the one doing
research in those in your area so by by
forming your own sentences and
statements from the idea that you just
took from other papers
then you can condense and you can
completely change the form or change the
text of the
change the text so that it is not
plagiarism anymore that's how
we do that's how we write some of the
introduction part okay
and any other questions
uh i hope vitia that answers your
question
um since we are running out of time we
might take some questions after i finish
this um introductory part so in the
spring semester um omits logic in march
2022 had some of the great workshops
such as ngs single cell data analysis
and single cell rna project support
media analysis of cancer mutations using
next generation sequencing and the most
exciting and upcoming event is the only
thesis symposium
you can scan the qr code over here to
register for the omics research
symposium i heartily welcome you all for
attending it is a free to attend event
for students of all levels faculty
professionals and experts of all
background
you can stay connected with us by
joining us on facebook instagram
linkedin youtube and twitter uh it would
be really great for you if you can scan
this qr code and fill out the feedback
form so that we can come back stronger
and help you to get the sessions that
you already want
uh i would like to thank dr raghavendra
for his insightful talk once again we
were very happy to have you over here
thank you so much sir
and
with that i would like to end the
session and
pass it on to
shubridge are you there
thank you very much everybody it is it
is it is my pleasure to interact with
you all and it's it's as i mentioned
it feels really i feel younger when i'm
interacting with you all with with all
your bright minds thank you very much
for having me thank you
thank you very much sir everyone uh
that's the end of our meeting thank you
for joining and have a good weekend and
have a good night thank you bye
thank you everyone it was great to have
you all here if you have any questions
please feel free to email us in the
email id and show you the chat section
see you again soon see you at this
enclosure bye take care